Some pairs of heroes have decades-old rivalries
so heated it's almost a letdown when they
work together rather than fight each other.
But those rivalries aren't always based on
meaningful differences.
If you don't believe us, check out these superhero
rivalries that don't make any sense.
Batman vs. Superman
Frank Miller’s classic Dark Knight Returns
is one of the most influential Batman stories
of all time, and one of its most memorable
moments comes at the climax, when Batman takes
on Superman in what seems like a fight to
the death.
Sound familiar?
"What does that mean?"
Of course, Superman had been hit with a literal
nuclear explosion and a tank before Batman
threw his first punch, and a Kryptonite Arrow
from Ollie Queen during the fight, but a win
was a win.
This was the moment that took the aging Bruce
Wayne from a fallible human to a master strategist
who could take anyone down.
Before this story, no one really imagined
that Batman could present a physical challenge
to Superman, but with the success of a single
story, it became their default relationship.
Unfortunately, if you think about it for about
two seconds, it makes no sense.
If they really took each other on, Superman
could blast Batman with heat vision from orbit
before the Caped Crusader could hop off whatever
gargoyle he was perched on.
Then he could freeze the ashes with super-breath,
and throw it all into the sun.
The idea that Batman is cool enough to beat
anyone with enough prep time actually ignores
what’s really cool about Batman in the first
place.
If he’s the guy who’s smart enough to
figure out how to beat Superman, then he should
probably be smart enough to figure out that
he could get a lot more crime-fighting done
if a flying, bulletproof, super-strong farm
boy was on his side.
Daredevil vs. Punisher
Daredevil and Punisher have a rollercoaster
relationship where they find themselves teaming
up as allies just as much as they take each
other on as enemies.
When they work together, even after all these
years, Daredevil somehow seems surprised when
the guy with the skull on his chest who carries
all the military grade weaponry tries to kill
someone, and that's when the honeymoon ends.
The thing is, either one of these two could
easily end their rivalry without doing all
that much.
On one hand, Daredevil doesn’t have much
of a leg to stand on here.
He’s ostensibly battling the Punisher because
of his tendency to execute criminals without
giving them a fair trial first, but if Matt
Murdock really cared about the letter of the
law, he probably wouldn’t spend his nights
dressed up as the devil punching out ninjas.
Given that Frank Castle is usually portrayed
as pretty meticulous in selecting his targets,
maybe just take the lighter workload as a
win and leave him to it.
On the other hand, if he absolutely has to
murder criminals, Punisher might consider
just doing it somewhere other than Hell's
Kitchen.
Seriously, Frank.
Daredevil doesn’t really leave Manhattan
that often.
Just go kill people in Brooklyn and you’ll
be fine.
Flash vs. Green Lantern
When Kyle Rayner replaced Hal Jordan as Green
Lantern in the '90s, it was more than a little
controversial, with a vocal group of fans
demanding the return of the previous Green
Lantern.
They weren’t the only ones that were looking
down on Kyle, though.
They had an ally in one of his own teammates:
Wally West, better known as the Flash.
When the Justice League's flagship title was
relaunched in 1997 as JLA, Rayner and West
found themselves on the same team.
And while other members of the League had
doubts about the new Green Lantern, Wally
West was a straight-up jerk to him for most
of their time together.
Flash constantly trashed the new Lantern from
the very first issue, often suggesting or
outright saying he wasn't worthy of his power
ring.
Where did Wally's rage come from?
Wally had been a superhero since he was a
child as Kid Flash, and was upholding a legacy
that had been passed down to him by his mentor.
Kyle, on the other hand, was literally just
handed the most powerful weapon in the universe
at random out of desperation without ever
even paying his dues as a sidekick.
He was, however, the only Green Lantern at
the time, so what exactly did the Flash think
he was going to accomplish with his insults?
It’s not like they could’ve gotten a replacement.
Maybe he was just happy to not be the youngest
guy on the team anymore.
The Thing vs. Man-Thing
The Man-Thing and Ben Grimm, better known
to Fantastic Four fans as the Thing, didn’t
exactly have the storied rivalry of some of
the other pairs on this list.
Their conflict only lasted one issue, but
it’s worth mentioning for being one of the
most remarkably stupid reasons for two heroes
to fight that comics had ever seen.
The first issue of Marvel Two-In-One, a series
where Grimm teamed up with other heroes from
throughout the universe, opens with Bashful
Benjamin reading a newspaper article.
He becomes so furious that the swamp monster
has “stolen” the word “Thing” that
he takes a bus to the Florida Everglades in
order to beat him up for copyright infringement.
In typical comic book fashion, the two monstrous
good guys wind up teaming up to fight a supervillain
instead.
In the end, the Thing and Man-Thing don't
really fight all that much.
But just consider that in the first page of
the issue, the Thing is in New Mexico.
Imagine taking a bus trip from New Mexico
to Florida as a giant, mostly naked monster
so that you can beat up another monster for
having a name that’s kind of the same as
yours.
If that’s what the FF considers worthy of
violence, then maybe Doctor Doom actually
is the good guy here.
Superman vs. Shazam
Superman and Captain Marvel, better known
as Shazam, have had a rivalry that dates back
to the 1940s, and goes well beyond the comics.
Back then, DC sued Shazam’s publisher, Fawcett
Publications, claiming that their World’s
Mightiest Mortal was nothing but a knockoff
of the Man of Steel.
After winning the lawsuit in the ‘50s, DC
would license the Shazam characters and add
them to their universe where they moved their
fight back onto the page more often than not.
It doesn’t take a hardcore comic book fan
to figure out why this particular rivalry
doesn't make any sense.
It seems mostly based on two people beating
each other up because they have similar powers
and the shared love of capes.
What’s really disturbing about it, though,
is that Shazam is literally a child.
Billy Batson might transform into a body that
looks pretty grown-up, but he’s still a
kid at heart.
That means that Superman, emphasis on the
“man,” has spent their entire rivalry
getting into fistfights with a boy.
DC may have won the lawsuit, but in the panels,
it’s definitely not a good look for Superman.
Think about it.
When these two fight, if Superman wins?
Then Superman just beat up a kid.
If Superman loses?
Then Superman just got beat up by a kid.
Superman should do everything he can to avoid
a fight with Captain Marvel.
Let him stay up past nine or play all the
Fortnite he wants.
It’s worth it not to be known as the superhero
who beats up on, or gets beat up by, grade
schoolers.
The Avengers vs. the Defenders
Since they first gathered together on a day
like no other in 1963, the Avengers have been
made up of Earth’s mightiest heroes.
The Defenders, on the other hand... have not.
Despite occasionally sharing members, including
the Hulk and Doctor Strange, the Defenders
have always been a second-string team that
deals with the weirder side of the Marvel
Universe.
In other words, they don’t have much of
a reason to interact at all, let alone throw
down in a massive, multi-issue fight.
That’s exactly what happened in 1973, when
Marvel launched a crossover event known as
the Avengers/Defenders war.
Spread out over eight issues which would be
a long story today, let alone back in the
‘70s the event featured members of both
teams battling it out to capture pieces of
an artifact called the Evil Eye.
It wouldn’t be the last time they’d fight,
but it was for the dumbest possible reason.
The demonic Dormammu and Loki manipulated
the teams so that each one thought the others
were gathering up the Evil Eye’s pieces
for nefarious purposes.
You’d think this could all be solved if
Captain America just called up Doctor Strange
and asked what was going on, but to be fair,
the Defenders’ roster boasted the Hulk and
Prince Namor, both of whom have occasionally
been supervillains.
That said, the actual reason the Avengers
turned on their would-be compatriots came
when Loki you know, the God of Lies?
showed up at the mansion and told them the
Defenders were up to no good.
Since they had absolutely no reason at all
to believe that the lying liar who hated them
and wanted to destroy them might not be telling
the whole truth, the fight was on.
Think it through next time, guys.
Superman vs. Flash
The ongoing contest between Superman and the
Flash isn’t the kind of violent conflict
where the characters come to blows, but it’s
gone on long enough to be one of the greatest
rivalries in superhero history.
Ever since 1967's Superman #199, the Flash
and the last son of Krypton have occasionally
raced because of the question fans have wanted
answered for decades Who's faster?
Superman or the Flash?
It's a good question, but with over 50 years
behind us, it’s a little weird that we’re
still asking it.
Since both characters count super-speed among
their powers their only power, in the Flash’s
case they’re both limited only by the creators’
imaginations.
As a result, the arguments in favor of each
hero have gotten truly ridiculous.
The Flash is fast enough to vibrate through
solid objects, but Superman can’t!
Superman is fast enough to time travel under
his own power, but Flash needs a special high-tech
treadmill to do it!
It’s weird stuff.
At the end of the day, though, Superman is
bulletproof, strong enough to bench-press
mountains, can jump to the moon without breaking
a sweat, and shoot lasers out of his eyes
that can blow up cars.
Can’t he just let the guy with “The Fastest
Man Alive” on the cover of his comic win
this one once and for all?
Hulk vs. Wolverine
The absolute king of nonsensical superhero
rivalries also happens to be one of the most
popular — Wolverine and the Incredible Hulk.
There is something undeniably cool about the
match, and it really does fit with Wolverine's
character.
He’s a small but vicious warrior set against
the biggest, strongest monster he could find.
It makes for good art and maybe even a good
issue – one good issue.
Maybe two.
Wolverine is a scrappy brawler with unbreakable
bones and razor-sharp claws, but he’s also
the kind of hero who’s frequently beaten
up by another guy with claws who’s slightly
taller.
The Hulk, on the other hand, has punched out
gods, lifted mountains on his back, and held
his own against every other hero in the Marvel
Universe on more than one occasion.
Wolverine isn’t the guy who’s really going
to go toe-to-toe with him and pick up a victory.
It’s even backed up by their very first
meeting in Incredible Hulk #181, when the
Hulk took Wolverine out with one relatively
light bonk on the head.
Maybe stick to slugging it out with Cyclops
from now on, Logan.